now is it true that you didn't want
Olympiad to go to matches because you
were afraid you would lose Killer
Instinct
well I just referred I would get
distracted because I would be like wait
is she drinking is she doing this so she
came to a match once like super brief
and I was like oh my God is she wearing
sun cream like is she you know it's nuts
and so I would get stressed out I'm
thinking oh my goodness
wait a minute I Gotta Serve
this makes no sense so so yeah and I've
never really had her at matches until
like my last this this summer actually
and in a match where she came
[Applause]
she's so fun
she came to a match that is the most
watched moment in tennis history
[Music]
and you won the match yeah
did that
did that
assuage fears or calm something down
absolutely apparently she was saying
like Go Mama I'm so proud of you and I
was like what and no so then she comes
back like after I had I lost in
Cincinnati she came back and she's like
it's okay Mama you just have to do what
you feel and I like literally wanted to
cry it was like do what you feel do what
your heart tells you you know and she
was so I was it was the sweetest thing
ever and I was so proud of her yeah that
little thing oh it's the best her dad
Alexis um I was reading a story about
how you guys first met is this true that
you were at a restaurant with friends
yeah you needed a table he was in the
vicinity or maybe at the table you
wanted is this is this am I correct so
far ah some pieces of it are real okay
some pieces of it are real yeah so we
were at this restaurant and um it was at
the hotel we were staying at and I was
in Italy and this guy shows up and the
whole place is empty
and this guy like really tall he comes
with his computer and he like plops down
right next to us and he opens his
computer and he starts typing and I'm
just like
why I was so angry I was like why is
this guy here and so we try to get rid
of him
[Laughter]
[Applause]
so we tried to get rid of him and I was
like you know my friend was like listen
there's a rat over there and he's an
Aussie guys oh my God this rat and I'm
like yeah there's a rat and he doesn't
Flinch he looks and Alexis looks and
doesn't Flinch and I'm like you're not
afraid of rats he's like um no I'm from
Brooklyn but uh is there even really a
rat there I guess he always knew I was
full of stuff and um and so then
um that's how we met so it was just yeah
I was just trying to get rid of him and
then
is it true that like you find out that
he's the inventor of Reddit yeah yeah
okay
so I didn't know what Reddit was
and then we're like oh we love that and
he's like oh have you seen it what do
you like and I was like
[Laughter]
uh we're like it yeah
and we were just laughing and it was it
was funny and then that was that but it
was then how did you meet each other
again so you want more of the story yeah
okay then what happened before the story
too okay so then
so obviously you get you could
understand that Alexis has a lot of
patience to deal with this so a lot of
people ask him questions so I leave
because I literally was asking a good
intentions I was just asking his number
I left because I had a match that night
and um so I met my match and then I I'm
done I win the match and I'm going home
and this guy gets in the car and he's
like six five and he's big and I'm like
what is this guy getting in the car with
this for so I look over at my age and
I'm like Jill like what is this guy
doing like why do I have security like
you need to tell me about stalkers
because I you know it have you you know
how stalkers I do sadly so yeah I'm like
you need to tell me when I have stalkers
because that's not fair that I need to
know so I can be prepared you know like
if something happens I want to be ready
you know and she's like no no that's
Alexis
so because he's really tall and so I was
like six five he's six five and like so
I thought he was the security and like
Hi man I don't know what he was doing
like I don't know why
but like had you invited him to the
match like where did he appear from so
my age when she's like oh it's Alexis
yeah so she had invited him because we
ended up having a mutual they ended up
having a mutual friend so when he came
to the match I was like okay so we just
and we just stayed in contact and it was
it really wasn't anything for a long
time because we were just you know just
texting and I was asking questions and
it was that and so that was was there a
there was there an attraction or did it
grow like well yeah I mean he's an
incredibly handsome guy so yeah I think
it was there he thought he was handsome
yeah I thought he was he was all right
but uh in case he's watching no I'm
kidding it's always so interesting to me
like how it happens you know timing it's
all a lot of timing yeah yeah does it
grow out of a friendship you know is
there love at first sight is it a story
about all of them I think it's all of
them you know like there's no one way to
cook a chicken yeah you can fry it you
can bake it you could season it you can
shake and bake it
did you have an official first date or
did you and what was that yeah so we had
a first date
um I was joking I was like listen listen
you need to um come because I played bad
that day or whatever it wasn't like my
best match and I was just saying it as
an aside like yeah you have to come you
know to Paris to see me play for real
and it wasn't like I had I literally did
not want him to come I like was not
thinking about it that way or anything
and then he's like oh yeah I'll be there
and I was like oh man what have I got in
myself too but it was good so we went
out after we met in Rome our first date
was in Paris
so you met in Italy yeah you have a
first date in Paris yeah I'm a hopeless
romantic too
well you are the ultimate goat and I was
wondering if you would share being
um some of your ultimate goats for you
what's your goat will you share it with
us yes okay
[Music]